there's a special guest here who let him
walk in and wish you a happy birthday
here's your first guest of the morning
for your birthday show mystery guest
can't imagine he's gonna just walk in
he's here for your day mystery guest
please enter and sign it no actually
Dave Chappelle is here for your birthday
rough man not even plugging anything
right now I wouldn't miss this for the
world just how old Robin is it's hard to
tell what black people write like my day
Chappelle time land oh my god am I just
making guess I'm trying to think man I'm
going off that commercial you hit in DC
with the bags on your head right you
pass that the bags on the heap that'll
do it that's the time line to Dave
Chappelle time that was 21 years ago
Robin was probably about 23 there you
have it 21 plus 23 is 43 Wow well that's
very nice she's 50 all right Dave
Chappelle is here of course but Robin
I'm gonna put a mystery phone call
through to you and see if you can
identify who this is wishing you happy
birthday thing mystery caller yes I know
it's the President of the United States
who is it Robin it's Jon Bon Jovi
this is exciting Robin's birthday and
also today is the day that John is
releasing his new single wow I wonder
how much money you have a lot I mean
it's got to be a few but it's a lot more
than I have you know I know that why do
you know this because you sold 80
million records 99 million I'm sorry
90 million 90 million records like
that's that's like ridiculous amount of
Records alright anyway John
congratulations I get back thank you
John calling in from his jersey mansion
90 million reck 90 million records oh so
many people want to wish you happy
birthday a lot of celebrities too
really yeah oh yeah hi this is Chuck
Norris and I'd like to wish Robin a
happy 50th birthday hi this is Andy
Richter and a happy birthday Robin hey
Michelle and I want to wish you a happy
birthday this is David wells of the New
York Yankees and I'd love to wish Robin
a happy 50th and many more hi Robin this
is Tiffany happy 50th birthday hey Robin
is Tommy Lee wishing you a happy 50th
birthday hey Robin you better accept me
50 years old baby happy birthday to you
hey Robin this is the rock I just want
to wish you a happy 50th birthday the
big five oh don't look a day over 22 you
keep laying the smack down on all their
candy asses smell what you're cooking
honey well everyone wishes you a happy
birthday Robin I want to thank first of
all Dave Chappelle for coming in here